you know i did kind of shoot myself in
the foot with the title of this series
of videos
music in the islamic world is such an
enormous category that
covering it comprehensively would just
take way
too much time but in this part two
i will do my best to cover in a very
general sense the
post medieval period of music in the
you say islamic world in a general sense
and across a wide geographical
area there is a whole lot to cover here
but
all of it is very interesting and
inspiring so let's get to it
[Music]
this video as always is brought to you
by our patrons
the new ones include robert j eilers
ariel hamsa and conrad and as
always i would like to give a special
shout out to our saints
wasif khan greg corbin adam shraibi
al muhammad hanan fikri siya jafari
amulatif
stuart cleland and two new ones
sandy jabbard and muhammad mudasir
thank you all so so much i will leave a
link to our patreon page in the
description
if you want to join as well in part one
i talked about the earliest developments
in music
and in the islamic world generally from
the earliest arabic musicians like ibn
misja
and the later the andalusian ziryab
during the abbasid times as well as some
of the great music theoreticians of the
medieval period like al kindy
al-farabi ben sina and the
safa i ended the episode by discussing
the
great music theorist and composer safiya
din urmawi from baghdad
and his monumental book called the kitab
al-adwar
where he systematizes mutual theory to a
degree that no other had
up to that point and he had a massive
impact
on the future trajectory of music in
the middle east and also also in sort of
central asia
and or really a wider sort of a very
wide geographical span generally from
north africa to
to india and this is really where our
story picks up
if you remember what i said last time
music was almost exclusively an
oral thing at this time but with urmawi
we find some of the first
examples of music notation now there are
some earlier people who have attempted
to do very simple notations like al
kindly for example
he didn't write more than basic ud
exercises
but in urmawi we find much more
comprehensive musical notation
even if in his case it wasn't that
sophisticated either it's really just a
showcase of how one can write music
notation not
so much a composition or a full song as
such
but in the year following ormawi people
would study
read and write commentaries on his great
book like
like the kitab al-adwar and also develop
the
notation system that he that he
presented
and develop it even further in the great
iranian polymath khutbadin al-shirazi
famous as a great scientist and
philosopher we find a commentary on
urmawi's kitabal aduar but also a much
more comprehensive example
of music notation in fact shirazi wrote
down an entire composition by al-ur maui
himself
in a notation system that is quite
clever and which has been transposed
into western notation today
you can actually find this notation and
play it if you want i don't know where
to find it i've tried myself but i know
that it is out there somewhere
it's very fascinating notation system is
very unique and significant
he made some clever innovations to
urmaway's system
but strangely no one after him seems to
have used
this system so while shirazi is an
important historical figure for various
reasons
including for his writings on music he
didn't influence the music tradition
going forward to any huge degree
either but the same can definitely not
be said for another
slightly later figure called abdulkadar
al-maraari
abdul khadr al-marari was born in marare
in modern-day azerbaijan
he was a master musician but also a poet
and
painter a kind of polymath in the
cultural world
he stands at a very important crossroads
in history
right at the transcitionary period
between the chaotic post-ambassad
centuries
and the rise of the modern islamic
empires like the ottomans
the safavids and the mughals and
al-qaeda's writings on music were
immensely influential he wrote
several treatises on the subject the
most important to which is called jamia
al-haan which means something like the
encyclopedia or collection of music
he also wrote a commentary on
al-urmaiwis kitab adva
as well as a persian treatise by the
name of makkah
al-alhan which was supposedly dedicated
to the ottoman sultan murad ii
and it is in this connection with the
ottoman empire
that is especially significant because
became very influential and important
for the later development
of ottoman music which in itself is one
of the most important periods for the
development of what we know as
arabic and turkish music today what is
also significant about abdul khadr
al-marari
is that he much like shirazi and urmawi
also wrote musical notations but with
al-marari this is the most
comprehensive yet in fact this is where
we get
probably the first and best example of
full songs and compositions several of
them
notated in in a in a way that can be
easily read even today
and with him thus we get a couple of
full compositions that survive
even to this day this makes him one of
the earliest examples of proper music
notation in the islamic world
and in the world generally some of the
songs have become classics and one of
the most popular ones is called
ahmed nasi misub them
[Music]
[Music]
and this is really where we get into
these so-called gunpowder empires
the great empires of the modern period
like the ottomans the safavids and the
mughals
all of whom would develop music theory
and musical practice
forward in various different directions
as well as
developments also taking place in places
like western north africa as well which
was
somewhat separated from these great
empires and all kinds of genres
continued to be developed and played
from more secular court music and in the
courts of the kings and the sultans to
very religious and
sacred music of the sufis i did talk
briefly about sufism in part 1 and said
that i will make a separate video
dedicated just to sufi music
and this is still true i still plan to
do this but when going forward here it
would be impossible to talk about music
without talking about
sufism also in fact from the 12th
century or so onward
sufism had become basically the majority
expression of islam
and would remain so up until around the
19th century
so when we talk about music in the
islamic world from this point
it is often and usually deeply
interconnected with the
or even direct and sort of a direct
result of
the practice of the different sufi
orders
sufi music greatly influenced more
secular forms of music at this time and
also vice versa
in the ottoman empire music became a
great
and important part of courtly life
religious life and also just
everyday life the music that was
developed in the ottoman regions in
particular in
the capital of istanbul was greatly
influenced by the writings and practice
of some of these earlier
individuals that we have discussed so
this means that influence was taken from
persian music but also from arabic music
and from
more sort of local anatolian and turkish
music
early notable composers include the
famous cantimere and others but
a large bulk of the composers and
important musical figures of the ottoman
empires
were actually the sufis of various
different orders
primarily those of the mev levia the mev
levia or mev levy order is a sufi tariqa
that was established in konia
around the teachings and personality of
the very famous poet and master
din rumi this order came to great
prominence during ottoman rule and was
often accepted and greatly respected
as a sufi order with close contact with
the ottoman
court it was often seen as an orthodox
sufi order that stood firmly within the
bounds of islam and its law
often in contrast to other orders like
for example the popular baktashi order
which instead experienced kind of
fluctuating periods of sometimes
approval
and sometimes disapproval and
condemnation but what is especially
important for our discussion today is
that the mev levy order
has a very strong musical tradition
the ritual or ceremony that is called
sema which has become very famous across
the world
due to the what is often called the
whirling dervishes
through this ritual the medley order
made music
and what you could call a certain form
of dance
an important and central aspect of their
religious practices
and during ottoman times the sama would
develop into quite a sophisticated art
form or genre of music
that produced some very prominent
composers both within the order itself
but also in the courts of the ottoman
sultans the ritual itself as we have
said is often called
sema which derives from the arabic word
samaa which means
listening it is a word that denotes all
kinds of music related rituals in sufism
as well as some other rituals
and the particular musical composition
or sweet that is used in the sama of the
medley order
is referred to as the ayin being a
musical sweet it is a longer musical
movement that includes several
independent sections all of which are in
the same
macam or musical mode kind of like a
scale in
western terms the entire sema ceremony
can last
up to an hour so it's quite a long
ceremony
and the music was written to to fit
within this
larger ceremony with various sections
it usually starts with a song eulogy to
the prophet muhammad
followed by taksim which is an
improvisation on the nave flute
after this the musicians play a
so-called peshrev
a composed instrumental piece and the
next step
then is the ien itself so this is when
the dervishes will remove their black
robes and start whirling this very
characteristic dance and while this is
happening the ain
so-called is sung with musical
accompaniment and consists of
four independent parts all symbolizing
different
spiritual states after this there is
usually another improvisation on the nay
before the whole ceremony is closed
through a recitation of the quran
this as you can tell is a pretty complex
and sophisticated
musical structure and all of it with the
exception of
the improvisations of course were
sometimes composed by a single
master from the order some of these
composers are still known and many of
their compositions still serve
as the musical accompaniment for sama
ceremonies today
they include figures like mustafa dede
osman dede
and one of the most important and famous
ismail de de effendi what is significant
about these sufi composers
is that they were often close with the
courts and also served as
some composers of secular court music as
well indeed aside from the spiritual
music of the sufi orders
there had developed a great tradition of
court music in the ottoman empire as
well
of course religious music was played in
the court as well but a lot of this
music was more
secular in nature it was
functioned as entertainment for the
sultans and and the
other officials and members of the
palace and the courts
the ritual compositional suites of the
mev levis are known as i said as ayin
but similarly they're developed very
sophisticated musical suites in secular
form which became known as the fossil
just like the ayin the facet is also a
long form musical composition of various
parts
and all of whom are in the same macam or
musical mode
and indeed whereas these two different
forms of
musical compositions the ieee and the
fossil had become
different categories by the 17th century
the two influenced each other to a great
degree the
mevi composers took inspiration from the
fossil music the secular music and vice
versa
and as we've seen the composers of these
two forms of music were often also the
same people
in the words of musicologist walter
feldman quote during the later
17th century the composers of vain such
as mostafa de de osmande and mustafa
italy
were also composers of the courtly
fossil but the courtly fossil and the
medley
in were already two distinct musical
structures
the very varied ottoman musical
tradition which took inspiration from
various different sources and different
traditions of music from within the
middle east and central asia
and to santa girls in north africa is
the basis and a very important
point in the development of middle
eastern music today so
you could say in a way that when we
listen to arabic or turkish and
also persian music today that owes a lot
to the music of the sufis and in the
ottoman context this was not only
limited to the mev levy order
some other major sufi saints and
personalities were involved in musical
composition as well
like for example mahmud hudai the
founder of one of the other major sufi
orders in the ottoman heartland
the helveti order as well as also being
the sheikh
of sultan ahmed the first who is famous
for building the blue mosque
instruments that were common in the
ottoman repertoire changed and varied
across the centuries of course
but common recurring ones include the
nay flute
particularly in the mev levi sema as
well as the
sars the kemence a boat instrument
as well as different percussion
instruments and of course the wood
we must however of course remember that
the ottoman empire was
large the ottoman empire stretched they
ruled
basically all of the western middle east
and large parts of north
africa as well as the arabian peninsula
including the hijaz
which includes mecca and medina and
music
in these various regions of course
differed greatly as well
but what can be said about this period
in general this period of
the ottoman empire and thus also of the
safavids and the mughals
is that this period is all very greatly
responsible
for the you can say the separation of
what we call persian music on one hand
and arabic and turkish
music on the other it is from this point
on that we start to see a kind of
clear distinction between these genres
or or forms of music if you've been
paying attention you probably noticed
that
at least in the last episode when we
talked about the middle ages
the categories of you know arabic music
and persian music
was very blurred they of course came
from
different traditions originally but from
the
9th or 10th century onwards they started
to
develop very much in harmony you could
say
and and the alliance between these
genres and traditions become very blurry
for a while
of course there were many certain
distinctions between them
as many of the writers affirm including
al kindly for example but
at the same time there was an increasing
sense of a common framework upon which
all of it was based
which we can see very clearly in figures
like al-uramawi for example
but with the arrival of the so-called
gunpowder empires
the ottomans and the safavids in
particular there was now an increasing
political and cultural boundary between
the larger persian region
largely ruled by the safavids and the
arabic and turkish-speaking regions
mostly ruled by the ottomans so from
this point on we see an increasing
distinction
being created between these kinds of
genres persian music developed in its
own
trajectory and tradition and even
created a modal system
that was some somewhat distinct from the
macam system that was used in the west
the persian system of modes is called to
this day dustgras
whereas in both arabic and turkish music
it's still called makam
and if you listen to persian music today
you'll find that it is quite distinct
from arabic and turkish music
the later two of which are while of
course having
individual characteristics and unique
features are a lot more similar to each
other
than they are to persian music this is
at least in my opinion
in any case that's not well on these
things for too long but this is an
interesting example to show
that many of the sort of cultural
distinctions and
things like that that we experience
today often have very clear
political or social reasons or
backgrounds that we don't
often think about as i've just mentioned
the rule or period of the
safavid and khajar dynasties in iran or
persia
is very important for the development of
what we know
as persian classical music today the
arts of the shi'i safavid dynasty is a
source of
endless fascination it showcases some of
the most
mind-boggling and beautiful architecture
in
the in history of the world for example
the just
incredible mosques in isfahan for
example and when we look at other visual
art from this period we find for example
very beautiful paintings depicting
musicians playing their instruments
which paints the picture of a thriving
court music culture in safavid persia
strangely in spite of this not a lot of
research has been done
on the music of the safavid period
in other words it is quite an
understudied field at least and
especially in the western or
english-speaking academic world
there is one book written by the
musicologist owen wright called music
theory in the safavid era
which translates a text from the period
and explores this culture through it
but other than this there isn't a lot to
go on when it comes to western academic
literature in english
but it seems clear that this period
brought us some very significant
developments
just like in other parts of the islamic
world inspiration was
drawn here from the writings of
safiyadeen al-urmawi
as well as the native persian alhadra
al-marari
and their systematization of music
theory
again as mentioned it is the periods of
the safavids and later khajurs that we
see a gradual movement
away from the more tightly knit musical
culture of medieval times
and thus a stronger separation between
arabic turkish and persian music
brought on by at least partly by
imperial borders this is true both in
sound and also in things like
instruments in persian music today and
thus in these earlier periods
instruments like the tar the setar the
tampur and kamenche
are all very characteristic features
here as well as
the uld of course which if you watch my
other videos probably originated as a
persian instrument called
the barbat the music of iran today is a
direct result of the developments that
took place during the salvation and
khajur dynasties which in itself of
course were
developed from earlier traditions still
the musical scene of iran and its
neighboring regions today is a thriving
musical scene that has produced some of
the most noteworthy and inspirational
singers and musicians
working today in the musical world if we
then move
even further to the west and to the
indian subcontinent
we realize that here music was also a
very significant part of both
everyday life and religious practices
in fact even prior to mughal time some
of the
main musical genres and traditions had
already started to be developed in this
region
taking inspiration from the developing
tradition in the western islamic world
and writers like al-urmawi
but also of course the native musical
culture
in india there developed a very
characteristic
and unique form of music or different
forms of music
in this context and of course like in
many other regions at this time the
sufis played a major
part in this development one of the most
significant figures of the late medieval
context
is the famous poet and musician amir
khusro
he was a student of the great sufi saint
nizamuddin auliya
and belonged to the shishti order of
sufism
the shishti order or shishtiya had
developed largely in india and become
one of the most prominent tariqas in
that region and
remains so until today just like the mev
levy order the shishtis have placed a
large
emphasis on music or sama as a religious
practice and with some of the earliest
figures of the order like amir khusro
they developed different forms of sufi
music all
inspired by local indian traditions
indeed amir khusra himself is attributed
with
inventing many instruments and musical
genres
including the most significant and
popular form of
sufi music called kawali whether it is
in fact true or not that he invented all
of these things
is of course hard to say a lot of it is
probably
more legendary than based in actual
historical truth
but it shows you the very important very
importance of amir
in the tradition of sufi or islamic
music on the indian subcontinent his
poems are still
sung in kawali performances today and
there are
regular kawali ceremonies at his tomb
also performed at this very uh
moment and maybe not but at least today
this is still happening regularly
kawali is still a very popular form of
music today and it has been
made famous even in the west by singers
like nostrad fatali khan in the 20th
century
and all of this goes back originally to
the shishti
order it has as mentioned a very
characteristic indian
sound and often includes instruments
like the harmonium
and tabla percussion but it is heavily
focused
on vocal performance of different sufi
poems
it's a vocal form of music primarily but
it is accompanied
by these instruments like the harmonium
which is almost like
it looks almost like an accordion but
it's quite different at the same time
and and different forms of percussion
like the tabla you can watch
kawali performances on youtube there's a
bunch of it it's very
fascinating and still a thriving musical
genre around the world
of course other sufi orders in india
also partook in different musical
ceremonies
with the possible exception of the
nakshbandi order which we've talked
about in a previous video
but the koali genre of music is
primarily
associated with the shishti order and
similar to the ottoman case but perhaps
not to the same degree
the music of the sufis affected the
general music scene in india as well
during mughal times the sushi order and
their sama ritual was very influential
and they were sometimes quite close to
the court even though the shifty order
has
usually maintained a kind of
non-political
disassociated attitude towards these
things
but for example some sources indicate
that the emperor akhbad was a
shishti devotee but as is often the case
this practice and
music generally has also faced some
opposition the more puritanical emperor
aurangzeb more
associated with the nakshbandi order is
said to have forbidden music for a while
during his rule
now some reason scholarships have shown
that this might not actually be entirely
true but it shows that the practice has
sometimes been controversial
but still kowali and the music of the
sufis in india has been a significant
factor on these subcontinents since
and is an important part in the puzzle
of music
in the larger islamic world when it
comes to the
most western parts of the islamic world
places like what is known as the maghreb
which is
western north africa we're talking
morocco algeria tunisia
even here there is further diversity of
course
the ottoman empire ruled much of the
arabic-speaking world than much of north
africa but not all of it so
parts of the maghrib were often outside
of ottoman controlled
which created you know even though
within the ottoman empire there was
diversity this creates an even more
diverse picture the musical culture of
the maghrib has always had a very unique
character
as we talked about in part one figures
early figures like ziryab
instigated a musical tradition and
culture in the maghrib
and in and lucia that was
that flourished and which survives even
to this day
there developed sophisticated forms of
music composition here as well like the
already mentioned nuba suite
which also includes the various section
in the same musical mode
much like the ieen of the mevi
context or the fossil in the more
secular courtly music of the ottomans
so the the the same kind of suite
which in north africa and the maghrib
was called nuba
had a similar sophisticated structure
but was also quite different at the same
time it had local and regional
characteristics
the noob suite includes again
improvisations vocal as well as
instrumental music the vocal
compositions often revolve around
characteristic poetic forms in the
region
like the moasha form of poetry for
example
of course during ottoman times it was
impossible for this region to not
be somewhat influenced by what was going
on further east in places like istanbul
but the maghreb still managed to retain
a very characteristic and unique
flavor in their musical culture even
things like the modes or the mccombs
used are sometimes
different traditionally i think i
mentioned in part one that
in the music of the western
world so north africa and andalusia
there isn't as much
use of quarter notes or micro tones
sometimes not at all actually whereas in
the more eastern parts
that stuff is a lot more common so when
we listen to music from this region we
can
often hear a clear difference from what
was going on further east
recurring instruments here include the
omnipresent udes
but also percussion instruments like the
reach and the bode instrument known as
rabbab
but secular or classical music is of
course not all that came out of this
region
just like everywhere else these sufis
and their music played an important role
here
much of maharabi music can be said to be
a kind of synthesis between arabic and
thus
partly persian music as well as the
traditions of the
local berber tribes a clear indication
of this
is the very famous gnawa genre of music
which is very common in morocco and the
maghreb generally
this style of music is very strongly
associated with sufism
and has been used in many sufi contexts
throughout history
but have its origins most likely outside
much like in india for example we should
look at these developments as
natural muslims took inspiration from
local cultural traditions and
incorporated them into their own
practices this is always what happens
now our music has a very unique sound
which employs characteristic instruments
like the sentir or gimbri
a three-stringed pluck loot as well as a
percussion instrument called krakebs
of course the islamic world is very
large and there's
no way for me to cover everything there
are distinct musical traditions in
west africa places like senegal and the
gambia as well
there are distinct musical traditions in
sudan
i haven't talked at all about the music
the fantastic music of the
kurds for example partly due to my own
ignorance on the subject but
all of that will have to wait for
another day what we can say as a
conclusion is that cultures
and thus music is always evolving these
musical
practices do not look the same in 900 as
they did
in 1600 and they continue
to develop and change even today
in the last century of the ottoman
empires of the 19th century for example
there was increasing cultural contact
with the western world so
europe for example sometimes friendly
sometimes not but in any case
this resulted in an increased
inspiration
taken from european musical tradition
for example
which then entered the ottoman world and
the middle east generally
in this way western music theory as well
as compositional techniques
made their way into arabic persian
turkish and so on music
and has affected the way that that music
functions and sounds today
egypt of course had a particularly
flourishing music scene in the
20th century with great western style
orchestras playing compositions by great
composers like
muhammad abdul wahab and often sung by
famous singers like umkulthum
or fei rules but this is nothing new as
i hope this series has shown you
the musical culture of the wider islamic
world has always been one of exchange
and
development the arabs took inspiration
from the persians
and vice versa the berber tribes in
north africa and the spaniards
influenced the wider musical culture of
andalucia and some of the greatest
periods of
flourishing and musical development has
been when these cultures and varied
traditions
have come together to inspire each other
and such is indeed the case today as
well with our increased globalization in
terms of communication for example
composers in the wider middle east and
the islamic world
are taking inspiration from their own
native
musical cultures and this vast history
that we've been talking about
but also from influences around the
world
in other words the story of music in the
islamic world
is far from over i'll see you next time
[Music]
you